[Music]
it's been almost a year since I've seen
my classmates it's been so long
everyone's gathered again together it's
a great Reunion yeah it's fantastic
[Music]
it feels like we never left and at the
same time it feels like it's been a
lifetime since we've been here
[Music]
it was a little surreal to be back I'm
actually coming from internationally so
to come all the way back here and to
have wonderful people put together this
weekend for us has been awesome
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
more than for having your college Years
coincide with a pandemic at its worst
for representing Yale
at its best
today we salute your sacrifice
sacrifice that has solidified your
rightful place
in history
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer upon you the decree as
designated by the dean and admit you to
all its rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]